[Music]
one of the great things about our
country and the way our Constitution
establishes that we have a marketplace
of ideas that means that people can shop
for those ideas that they want to hear
my hope is that more people would want
to shop for a variety of products ones
that come from a lot of different
suppliers ones that have a lot of
different ideas and perceptions and
perspectives and facts and experiences
that are shared but we live in a country
where you're free to get whatever you
want and if you want to shop on the side
where it's only one type of product
that's giving you one vision you have
the right to do that and that's not for
me to tell anyone not to do that it
would be unfortunate if he chose I think
if people limit themselves because they
do care and are interested in the
consumption of news I think it's really
important to try to be able to search
for different outlets and for different
opportunities to learn more and to get
educate yourselves one of the things
with our practice over the years has
been working with clients who have very
different political views they weren't
necessarily mine I've climbed to were
way more liberal than me and I've
climbed to are way more conservative
than me we only work on things
politically that we agree with but we
work with clients whose politics we may
not because being around people and
having discussions and learning about
them and appreciating and respecting the
point of view that they have are really
valuable for us to understand how to
reach people how to understand things
and truthfully you know I think it makes
us better people a little bit by the
fact that we try doesn't mean you're a
bad person if you don't but I think that
the more understanding you have of your
neighbor the more your have the ability
to find common interests and if you can
find those common interests then you'll
have a lot more respect for the
differences afterwards and hopefully
when you do go shopping you can find
those things at least a few things on
that shopping list that your neighbor
who may have different politics and you
would agree with may at least find a few
things they agree with because that
could then need help you talk about the
things you disagree with and at least if
we can start somewhere the same and then
build out from there and in order to do
that you have to sometimes taste-test
some things that you may not be used to
tasting now we live in an era where
individuals or brands of the
selves and that does not just apply to
athletes or to actors it also applies to
journalists and we've come to into an
era of a celebrity journalist of
journalists who are more trusted
especially in days where people have
questions about some things about the
media and one of the things that you see
in we've seen in the past was that
people would specifically just want a
story based on what publication had the
story as opposed to necessarily who was
going to write it now because we have
journalists who are more trusted who do
have Twitter followers who do have
larger influence and they're a way to be
able to to have to be followed
potentially by others there's going to
be a consideration about that reach that
goes beyond simply the outlet it goes to
the individual in addition the standards
that an individual reporter may have may
be higher or lower than that of the
publication for which they're working in
some cases the reporter as I mentioned
is above the standards are necessarily
the publication that they work for if
it's a more tabloid type environment
where the standards are a little bit
different and others when you even have
the highest and most respected
publications sometimes their standards
aren't exactly what you think they are
and the reporters who approach things
that aren't up to those standards and so
you just need to be careful of
considerable
[Music]